battus vassilev bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous nous sommes dehors mais
néanmois à l'atelier numérique de la rue
saint-simon à versailles voilà dans le
patio et nous sommes là parce que vous
êtes réalisateur et que vous allez
projeté un documentaire durant
l'événement le mois du cinéma donc on va
parler un petit peu de vous pour mieux
vous connaître et après on va parler
bien sûr de votre film documentaire donc
mathieu vous êtes réalisateur monteur
racontez moi oui je suis là j'ai
commencé moi en faisant du montage le
monteur et
la réalisation m'a toujours intéressé 1
et du coup j'ai eu l'occasion de faire
ce documentaire qui est mon premier
documentaire j'avais fait d'autres
petites choses avant notamment un court
métrage qui s'appelle sylvie clip tueur
qui était vécue petiot ça veut dire quoi
c'est les clips tueur en fait c'est un
jeu de mot avec sylviculture puisque le
film en fait et comme une espèce de
balade forestière en espèces de journal
de bord
donc qui a été qui a été filmé autour de
chez moi grosso modo sur le est-ce que
vous êtes si pas d'un jour il lui dit ah
vous êtes yvelinois vous avez grandi à
chevreuse voilà dans un endroit assez
magique un rat avec entourée de
forêts dans la foi voilà voilà et ça ça
vous a donc aspirer exactement court
métrage exactement donc il a fait un
clip finalement sur une musique
symphonique d'un compositeur estonien
qui s'appelle est requise benture
d'accord et donc voilà une balade dans
la forêt avec toutes les colères toutes
les choses que j'ai pu observer qu'ils
m'ont intéressé donc au rythme de cette
musique d'accord ça c'est une première
chose c'est votre premier court métrage
qui voilà après alors ils se trouvent
est-ce que je peux raconter à bien sûr
parce que tout est lié il se trouve que
votre maman claude mathieu et
sociétaires ont dit ses sociétaires à la
comédie française elle est aussi
dramaturge voilà et il se trouve qu'elle
est ami avec guillaume gallienne wii et
qu'il travaille évidemment ensemble sur
guillaume gallienne aussi et à la
comédie française seulement voilà donc
fièrement dans un cadre privé guillaume
gallienne l'acteur a vu votre court
métrage qu'il a beaucoup aimé
et apprécié et du coup il m'a demandé du
coup il a demandé de au moment où il
mettait en scène ce spectacle donc sur
la grand route de tchekhov voilà donc
ces il avait un projet mettre en scène
en fait à la comédie française les
acteurs ont l'air parfois les cartes
blanches donc qu'ils peuvent mettre en
scène un spectacle de leur choix l'écart
studio-théâtre donc là guillaume l'a
fait et il m'a demandé en fait de venir
filmer les répétitions pour faire un
court métrage qui serait projeté juste
avant le début du spectacle dans une
salle en fait le public attend avant de
rentrer dans la salle d'accord comme une
sorte de mise en condition soit 14 pour
les faire plonger dans l'univers les
mettre dans le bain avant le spectacle
alors c'est génial et l'or guillaume
gallienne bon on le sait d'ailleurs vous
aussi vous avez des origines russes ça
voilà tchekhov c'est donc pas par hasard
bah oui une différence ya une attirance
et une attirance commune vers vers vers
les racines qu'on
voit là est donc cette idée de courts
métrages que vous avez donc réaliser
c'est assez rare de voir ça oui alors
moi j'ai enfin ou partie d'une me semble
que non c'est oui c'est assez rare tout
le monde ne le fait pas on travaille et
ça ça s'est déjà vu ma gâteau d'accord
alors du coup pour réaliser ce court
métrage de d'entrée de spectacle comment
vous est pris eh ben je j'ai eu accès
déjà au huis clos des répétitions
qui est normalement quelque chose auquel
on assiste pas un qui est
traditionnellement peu protégés et une
fois que j'étais dedans j'ai tout filmé
donc j'ai fait ce court métrage donc été
voilà qui est et qui était censé durer
que mini voilà qui duré huit minutes de
moments d'errance un peu de de regard
dans le vie de décoller des comédiens
c'est ça qu'il fallait montrer site web
mélangez avec avec des eaux fait je
montrais un peu ce que je voulais et
guillaume avait demandé voilà tu vas tu
vas faire quelque chose de huit minutes
pourra mettre le spectateur un peu en
condition qui lui demain un peu un voile
comme un avant-goût autre manière de
venir bien le si doit être de s'immerger
un peu avant avant de rentrer dans la
salle de spectacles en plus le spectacle
commencé de manière un peu interactive
avec les avec les spectateurs puisque
les acteurs et les spectateurs rentrent
et en même temps ah oui il est rentré en
même temps dans la salle c'est une halte
en fait dans la pièce sur la grand-place
que les valeureux
oui et donc le moment de la pièce
correspond à une ait exactement
cheminement donc tous les personnages
rentre où commence le spectacle commence
tout le monde rentre dans la salle donc
là les spectateurs aient toute attente
rentré en même temps les acteurs des
fois ça y est à côté des spectateurs
donc voila c'était dans ce cadre là il
fallait voilà s'immerger préparation
j'ai donc s'adonner voilà
une idée voilà des répétitions des
moments voilà deux moments d'errance de
comédien en quelques partitions ses
errances par rapport aux à l'idée de la
route ou par rapport aux pays bas y
avait un lien qui se crée en fait entre
ce court métrage est et la route quoi le
spectacle eux mêmes parce que les
comédiens pendant les répétitions des
fois il disait un peu on est dans le
doute exactement et donc voilà c'était
des moments oui c'est en quelque part
des regards qui était voilà qui réunit
petits qui laissait entendre voilà ils
étaient dans leur imaginaire et
parallèlement je mélangeais des images
d'archivés voilà alors vous avez aussi
eu pour résumer vous m'avez dit que
votre grand père calixte
qualifie la vie que cela vic par la
ville
vasilyev était à décorateur voilà
passionnés pareil 2 darche yves normand
de livange général et que vous avez la
chance d'avoir accès à chis incroyable
je suis allé faire le mode je suis allé
faire mon marché dans sa dans sa
bibliothèque qui avaient énormément de
choses et d'un coup à saisir notamment
beaucoup d'image du début de la
photographie donc en russie
correspondait à l'époque de la pièce qui
était pour moi une manne effectivement
parce que les acteurs certains utilisent
beaucoup l'iconographie aussi pour
travailler c'est un moyen de colorer
leur imaginaire de pénétrer voilà non
dans dans le don dans une époque dans un
auteur dans une culture et donc moi j'ai
pas mal utilisé ça aussi dans ce
documentaire on les avait inclus dans le
film alors après donc vous vous avez
donc 106 heures 2 rue de roche ont dit
pas voulu sont des roches
106 heures et vous vous êtes dit un jour
j'en ferai quelque chose ouais une fois
que le spectacle a été fini de jouer bon
bah ça s'était terminé et puis voilà
donc vous êtes dit belge et coup c'est
peut-être bien d'en faire un
documentaire
oui ça sera plus conséquent je me dois
utiliser toute cette matière que vous
avez récolté des choses qu'on ne voit
jamais
moyenne chose qui m'a d'ailleurs ça
s'appelle de la table à la scène parce
qu'on assiste aux lectures à la table ce
que je trouve extrêmement intéressant
parce que c'est privé qu'on ne voit
jamais vous avez guillaume gallienne et
son acteur qu'il hisse grâce par phrase
choc qui est plus chaque nuance du mot
enfin c'est extrêmement subtile et
précis ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
découvre et c'est ce qui est génial
c'est qu'à la fois on nous on peut être
passionné théâtre ou passionnés de
cinéma on s'y retrouve quoi y aller nous
voilà je vais faire un documentaire qui
n'ont donc with the bass et ses rushs
sont restés un peu en stand by pendant
ses avants pendant une année puis je me
suis remis le nez dedans et en regardant
je me suis rendu compte que voilà il y
avait quand même de quoi faire beaucoup
de choses mais très intéressante donc je
suis parti de dont je me suis pris au
jeu je suis parti tout seul au départ je
pensais pas que ça ça aurait pu
intéresser arte où il se trouve que bon
bah ça a marché aussi avec arte et
c'était passionnant pour guillaume
qu'est ce qu'il en a pensé que guillaume
gallienne c'est aussi grâce à guillaume
c'est lui qui m'a qu'on dira qu'il m'a
donné les landes continue aussi oui je
lui ai montré première version génial je
vais montrer une première version et lui
m'a dit continue en quoi ça intéressant
on va peut-être pouvoir en faire quelque
chose quoi d'accord et donc voilà c'est
ce qu'on sait ce qu'on a fait et ça
fonctionne très bien ouais oui c'est
vraiment comme vous disiez on accède à
un domaine un univers complètement
préservée et que d'ailleurs tout le
monde ne fait pas forcément ce travail à
la table ça c'était certes un metteur en
scène de wallace et certains vétérans
scène ne font pas ce travail est là donc
en régalant services et la façon de
travailler guillaume l'a fait comme ça
il y en a d'autres aussi qui font comme
ça et c'est vrai que ça c'est un sas et
original ce travail à la table quoi
c'était banal c'est le côté je croyais
puis vraiment le tête à tête il ya une
vraie intimité dans ce travail là
puisque les visas car les caméras non
moi j'ai essayé de me rendre le plus
le plus invisible possible histoire de
pas du tout perturbé ce travail là parce
que c'est pas évident c'est vraiment
tout en finesse
moi j'ai ouïe j'essaie de me faire
oublier quoi très bien donc on va avoir
la chance de le voir parce qu'en
décembre certes il y a le 21 décembre le
jour le plus court mais il ya aussi tout
le mois du cinéma qui englobe cet
événement qui démarre du début du mois
de décembre à la fin du mois de décembre
avec plusieurs plusieurs manifestations
vous vous êtes le 16 décembre à 20h30
ici l atelier numéric rue saint-simon
vous allez donc projeté ce documentaire
qui dure 82 minutes ce sens voilà et
après vous serez à la disposition du
public pour échanger et
échanges et donc mathieu vasilyev voit
la famille donc comme on disait donc pas
d'acteur nom d'artiste puisque on n'a
pas dit mais votre père nicolas vasilyev
a composé et joué la musique du
documentaire entre autres parce qu'il
est aussi un transit d'entrain oui mais
lui reid sully la composent et morceaux
d'accordéon claude m oui morceaux
d'accordéon part dans claude mathieu
vous a conseillé ouais donc voilà elle
était présente mais les deux étaient
présentes et leur demander
leurs points de vue d'accord donc on va
découvrir ça comme on le disait le 16
décembre à 20h30 ici à l'atelier
numérique
donc tout ça ça s'est passé il ya un an
ou deux maintenant aujourd'hui vous en
ai tous aujourd'hui
mais nouveau projet c'est notamment un
documentaire sur le travail du
traducteur andré markowicz qui est en
train du coeur des auteurs russes comme
son nom l'indiqué comme son nom
l'indiqué dans la revue situe exactement
exactement que j'aimerais suivre voilà
en train de traduire notamment avec ça
avec sa femme françoise morvan est-ce
qu'ils travaillent ensemble travaille en
collaboration est d'accord et donc
suivre ce processus la singularité de
leur travail de traducteur en fait
d'accord donc sont des traducteurs
contemporain wiki aussi vous m'avez dit
interviennent quelques fois sur les
pièces de tellement souvent ils
interviennent ils sont appelés par les
metteurs en scène au début des
répétitions
pour des contrats du capial dont ils ont
traduit bien sûr pour pour donner voilà
des points de vue sur la manière dont on
peut se mettre en bouche le texte des
fois il leur arrive même de reprendre
leurs traductions pendant les
répétitions parce que les acteurs
peuvent tout d'un coup révéler quelque
chose auquel il a autrefois pensez donc
mis à l'épreuve de l'incarnation
procédure d'accord donc en fait ce
travail de traducteur n'allez pas filmer
quelqu'un assis à son ordinateur pendant
un mois non pas du tout entre autres il
y aura il y aura les discussions voilà
entre autres andré markowicz et
françoise morvan mais également
leurs interventions sur les routes
théâtre peut-être le suivre aussi en
russie dans les voyages qui fait là bas
bon ben voilà après je pense que je
prendrai aussi
enfin je ferai jouer un peu l'imaginaire
comme je lé fais dans de la table à la
sem parfois voilà je prends la liberté
d'interpréter un peu ce qui peut se
passer dans la tête d'un acteur ou un
traducteur mais tout ça en discutant
avec eux voilà pour donner un peu une
idée de ce qui peut se passer à
l'intérieur donc tout ça en images sous
forme de d'image des archives ou ou
d'image voilà peut-être de fiction un
peu comme pour guillaume finalement
c'est une personne et c'est son univers
qui nous est d'habitude cacher parce que
ce soit ce que vous racontez là sur le
traducteur moi je n'en avais pas
vraiment idée géniale bonne chance
bammer et puis déjà au 7 décembre ça
marche vous serai là très bien merci
mathieu au revoir au revoir